foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
trist welcomed her first child and for
Jesse the bundle of joy is a rainbow
baby arriving over a year after
revealing she suffered a miscarriage
Jessie's been open about her fertility
struggles getting candid with fans at
her shows her ex Channing Tatum was at
one of those concerts later writing on
Instagram quote this woman just poured
her heart out on stage
baby baby
it's hard to find one of a kind and when
it came time to share her pregnancy with
fans she admitted to being terrified but
also so happy I think it's crucial that
every child on the signs of that journey
is being a young person is different and
that everyone's problems are different
and everyone's needs and wants to
inspire a different and her A-list Pals
kept the love that's going Kelly Rowland
wrote quote screaming congratulations to
you Leona Lewis commented quote you look
completely radiant and full of joy wow
I feel nice
[Music]
and once fans got the news Jesse
documented her journey on the
grams
[Music]
yeah she didn't shy away from the ups
and downs
[Music]
congrats to the proud mom
good